we need to understand that we are living  through the biggest cultural shift of  our time you're gonna walk into your  refrigerator in a couple of years and  you're gonna open it and your  refrigerator is gonna be a smart  refrigerator just like your phone's a  smart phone now you know how this is  different than the brick that we used to  walk around with eight years ago  remember that this is different than  this right you're gonna walk into your  fridge and your fridge is gonna  understand that you're a pepsi drinker  and when you pull out your last Pepsi  cuz it's scanning it it's gonna order it  for you directly and it's gonna be  delivered to your home smart  refrigerators do you know that's bad for  Walmart Costco Target  I think we're massively under estimating  how big this culture shift is